ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
first statement of Deputy Prime Minister
minister of National Defense minor
swashak after the meeting with the
Canadian minister of National Defense
Madame Anita Anand
today I am announcing that in the coming
weeks Canada will deploy approximately
40 combat engineers to Poland to help
polish forces train Ukrainian sappers on
engineer reconnaissance explosives
Mining and demining this new training
under operation unifier will complement
Canadian training of new Ukrainian
recruits in the United Kingdom and
Canadian training of Ukrainian Personnel
on the use of the M77 howitzers that we
donated to Ukraine
and I would like to commend you
Minister as well as Poland
's leadership generally
for your sincere and remarkable efforts
in welcoming Millions
of ukrainians fleeing Putin's
unjustifiable
Wars
is
thank you very much for your kind words
and we are stronger together stronger
together exactly
[Applause]
okay thank you so much